Prof: Did I tell you the
story when one of my friends was
offered--to buy from me?
I was in upper Egypt and I was
traveling with a young lady,
and a third woman,
a little bit older,
sort of was traveling alone;
it's not terribly comfortable.
She asked to join us I and said
'that's fine,' so the three of
us were sitting there near
Aswan,
and there were two men sitting
sort of across the room.
One of them dressed in clearly
Arab garb,
and one dressed in a rather
modern suit,
and at some point the guy in
the suit came over,
introduced himself very
politely, and he was a
Palestinian and the other man
was a Saudi Arabian sheik,
and they had noticed that I had
two wives and so the sheik had
wanted to know--
would like to purchase the
second--the older one,
the second wife from me.
Since it was the somewhat older
one, he thought I wouldn't mind
very much.
It was a wonderful scene
because, as you know,
Palestinians are very
sophisticated;
they've been living with Jews,
who are basically Europeans,
for a very long time so they're
just like anybody else.
The Saudi Arabian sheik was
obviously living,
not in the modern world and
this poor Palestinian had to
intermediate,
so he was very scared how I
would respond.
Would I make a scene,
would I slug him,
would I try to get him
arrested, or any of this sort of
stuff?
Of course it was immediately
obvious to me what was going on
and to my two lady friends and
so we played it very cool and
we,
you know--please sit down,
let's discuss this,
how old is the sheik,
how many wives does he already
have,
how many has he divorced,
does he have any concubines in
addition to his wives,
how much money do you have,
etc., etc.
We had a very,
very nice polite thing and you
could just see the intermediary
his face just relaxed because he
was expecting something
terrible.
Everybody played along and it
went off very well,
and in the middle of this the
sheik calls the intermediary
over back to him,
and they talk something and out
comes a velvet purse given to
the Palestinian and he gives it
to me as a sign of good faith on
the part of the Arabian,
he wanted me to have this.
What is it?
A set of Muslim prayer beads,
beautiful cat's-eye stones,
many--not just a chain but
beautiful, beautiful handiwork
and probably very valuable.
I was looking for--to bring to
class--actually last time and I
can't find it right now.
Everything worked out,
the women paid very great
attention to what was going on,
and we said politely at the end
that we would consider and give
them an answer tomorrow.
In the end she didn't want to
be bought, even though she's
obviously going to have some
good chunk of change out of it,
or at least I was.
Two things will have to be
delayed because Eliezeri is not
here and we have to add
something to Noah's
presentation.
Let's skip that.
Last time we were discussing
Europe and we were coming into
the--
we started to discuss the
Middle Ages and we start with
Europe because we have the best
data.
We have very,
very good data about lots and
lots of things from Europe.
It's not so good from the rest
of the world.
From about--for about 500
years, from 1200 to 1700 the
data, poor as the data is,
shows that population really
didn't rise terribly much.
They were in some sort of
stasis.
The reasons for this we had
discussed a little bit.
We talked about the plague,
and the plague lasted like 500
years--
this is--remember the plague
hit Europe in 1347 so this table
where they have good data starts
200 years later.
The plague has been around for
200 years and still there's a
number of cases;
that's not individuals but
different cities and places in
which there was an outbreak and
we just don't have good records
of how many people died,
but 1550,1600,
1650, see the plague is dying
out slowly and there's many,
many theories whether people
got resistance to it,
or the rats that carried it,
died or were out-competed by
another species of rats.
Not known, but the plague did
eventually die out.
From 1347 to 1849,
is 500 years where the plague
keeps recurring.
That was clearly one of the
reasons why population couldn't
grow.
Then there was violence,
there was constant small level
violence,
and then when the Protestant
Reformation happened,
the religious wars broke out
and according to one of the
standard textbooks of European
history they ran from 1531 up to
1657,
so another 130 years of
slaughter and they rolled around
different places in Europe.
By the time they were done the
most contested--
southern Europe stayed
Catholic, and very northern
Europe became Protestant but the
middle of Europe was strongly
contested--
and so something like a third
to a half of everybody got
killed in this time because of
the religious wars.
This is the period that Malthus
is describing and we'll come
back to Malthus--that Malthus
knew about.
This is the history that he
understood and we'll come back
to what his theories were,
but the historians now agree
pretty much that productivity of
the land,
especially agriculture,
because that was the main
occupation,
was rising very slowly during
this period,
but population is also rising
very slowly during this period,
so pretty much the gains in
agricultural productivity were
balanced by the gains in
population and the average
standard of living did not
improve and we'll talk a good
bit more about that.
Now why--so the question I mean
is pretty obvious why they were
not able to improve agricultural
productivity,
why they were not able to
significantly improve any other
kind of manufacturing
productivity,
why they were not able to do
anything to fight these
diseases.
It comes down to,
that not only was there no
scientific knowledge as we
currently understand the word
scientific,
there really wasn't any
particular interest in--
intellectually in the real
world.
Everything was focused on
religion and the other world,
so there was not a lot of
intellectual energy expended in
trying to understand what was
going on around your feet so to
speak.
Because they had all kinds of
problems that we take for
granted,
all kinds of ways of dealing
with the real world just were
not even--
were not really thought about
in any serious way.
Sanitation, up until the
eighteenth century,
up until the 1800s actually,
the sanitation in Europe was
just absolutely atrocious.
There was no system for
disposing of human waste.
Nobody bothered to pay
attention to what to do with
human waste.
Feces were basically everywhere.
Wherever you went there was
someone else's feces.
In the eighteenth century the
city streets everywhere had
ditches down the middle of the
street and that's where the
feces got dumped.
There were buckets inside the
house and some servant,
or the housewife would take the
bucket and dump it into these
ditches.
They were also used as
latrines, people would just go
out there and if they didn't
have a bucket in the house,
or if they didn't have a house,
go in and do it in the latrine.
Again, in each case--I was in
Belize City in Latin--
in Central America as you know,
not that many years ago in the
middle of the street there's one
big latrine,
and the stink was just
incredible.
Now you didn't actually have
to--were not required to
actually take your bucket of
feces and dump them in the
street,
you could throw them out your
window.
But eventually people did start
thinking about that,
and the issue was not to dump
it on someone's head.
In Edinburgh,
Scotland they rang bells at
10:00 p.m.
at night when they figured
people should be off the street
and that was the specified time
for dumping excrement out your
window.
Some of the older of you that
were properly brought up--
the young men were maybe told
that you should walk on the
street side when you're
escorting a young lady.
Do you know what that's for?
When stuff gets dumped out the
window it's to prevent splash
from cars,
it's way earlier then cars,
it was to--
so that when someone dumped
stuff out the window it would--
the lady would be under some
kind of awnings there.
It wasn't only the common
people, the poor,
the uneducated that were living
in such filth,
it went right up to the royalty
and we have records of this.
In 1665, there was a great
plague in London,
one of those that I've showed
you there and that's the one
that--
written about by Robinson
Crusoe author,
Daniel Dafoe.
The King, Charles II,
and his court took his refuge
in Oxford University.
Now Yale is modeled after--a
lot of Yale is modeled after
Oxford, so you have a good image
of what it looks like.
The plague was over,
it took about a year,
the plague was over,
they went back to London and
just left whatever they left in
Oxford,
and the cleaning people came in
and what did they find?
Excrement everywhere,
they described it excrement in
every corner,
in chimneys,
in studies, in coal houses,
in cellars, just all over the
place.
Now some of this information
comes from the diary of Samuel
Pepys.
How many of you are aware of
this?
Some of you again if you've
taken history or literature,
he was the famous diarist from
that.
He was England's first
Secretary of the Admiralty,
a Member of Parliament,
President of The Royal
Scientific Society,
so he was not your ordinary
average guy.
He was educated,
had money and in the upper
classes,
but he writes that -- when he
had to defecate in the middle of
the night--
he didn't bother to go to the
privy,
he just deposited his feces in
the fireplace.
You can see that it was a
smelly place to live in.
Now along with no concern or no
thought about where you deposit
your excrement,
the idea of keeping drinking
water separate from this
excrement was not in anybody's
mind.
That very often if there were
public holes or someplace where
the public could go to do their
thing,
then maybe right next to it was
a drinking fountain.
In terms of the waste in the
streets, it wasn't just feces
but everything else was just
dumped into the streets.
England especially had lots of
animals, Europe had animals,
unlike China,
and when animals died--just
left in the middle of the street
to rot.
Butchers that pulled out the
entrails,
the guts of the animals and
inedible parts,
dump it in the street and so
the streets are just full of not
only human excrement but the
waste of all the animals,
and of course the flies and
insects lay their eggs in it and
grow,
and it's very unsanitary.
Dead people were not handled
any better than this.
As more people died,
the urban cemeteries got filled
up.
There was not so much space and
so they stopped burying the poor
people in--
properly in cemeteries but just
what they call 'poor holes,'
just large pits in which piles
of bodies were just laid out
side by side,
row by row, and row on top of
row and they were not closed
until they were full.
You had these pits of rotting
bodies just festering there in
the middle of all the cities
that had enough people to bury.
Of course the stench was just
overwhelming and the rich people
were not buried in these pits
but if they were--
they could be buried in
cemeteries,
but if they were really
important they bought space in
the church crypt or they
contributed money and got space
in the church crypt.
Many of you have undoubtedly
gone to churches and in the
basement they've got these
crypts of dead people and guess
what?
They were rotting and stank,
so the churches stank.
One quote is that 'they stank
out parson and
congregation'--that people just
couldn't stand to be there.
In 1742, Dr. Johnson,
who you know wrote The Life of
Boswell--excuse me,
Boswell's Life of
Johnson, so he's quoting
Johnson.
Described London as a city,
"Which abounds with such
heaps of filth as a savage would
look on with amazement."
The death rate--cities were so
unhealthy from all this filth
that the death rates were
enormously high and cities did
not keep themselves going.
If left to itself a city's
population would just disappear
and some estimates are that
about every generation,
about a third of the
inhabitants of a city would die.
I mean everybody died,
but the population left--
the city just left to itself
would go down by a third in
every generation,
and the only reason that cities
were able to prosper was that in
the countryside where things
were healthier just because of
space,
there wasn't the demography,
there wasn't the crowding of
people that constantly the
excess births,
the excess population from the
countryside would keep migrating
into the cities because they had
primogeniture in England,
for instance.
Only the oldest son could
inherit the land,
so younger sons had to migrate
into the cities or into the army
and that's what kept the cities
going.
There's a constant stream of
people coming in from the
countryside.
Now it's not only London and
the great cities,
and it's not only that part of
Europe,
but we have descriptions of
some of the other cities,
and one of them is currently
politically very relevant.
It is Jerusalem and now all the
great Western religions claim
that Jerusalem is central to
their religion and they compete
viciously;
they fight viciously over
Jerusalem.
They all claim that they've
been interested forever in this,
but in fact,
… until Napoleon's
expedition to Egypt in the
Middle East,
it was totally ignored as a
physical thing from the crusades
to Napoleon it was totally
ignored.
In 1840 it was a tiny town of
15,000 people;
7,000 Jews;
5,000 Muslims;
3,000 Christians from the
records that we have.
In a place like that,
presumably the seed of the
Western religions,
the feces were 50 feet deep and
had been collecting since the
destruction of the second temple
by the Romans.
Before the Romans destroyed
Jerusalem there was some sort of
sanitation going on,
but between then and 1840 the
feces just kept going up.
Of course in this filth
everybody was sick.
Basically everyone had malaria,
and malaria was endemic there.
When cholera came through,
which it came periodically,
75% of the people would die of
it and one quote describing
this,
"The sanitary condition of
the city of God insure that any
pilgrim who sought to spend his
last days on earth there could
look forward to fulfilling that
ideal with great dispatch."
Personal cleanliness:
this was also unknown.
We have one professor of
medieval history who gives a
great lecture and if he ever
gives it as a public lecture
that I've seen him give.
If he ever gives it again
absolutely go.
It's called '1,000 Years
Without a Bath,' so this is in
Europe,
the Romans were very careful
about personal cleanliness and
they built these great big
baths.
… Have you visited the
baths of Caracalla in Rome;
a couple of you have.
How about Bath--the city in
England named after its baths
and so forth?
All these are Roman creations,
so the Romans very careful,
as much as they could in a
place like that with personal
hygiene.
But after the fall of Rome the
morality changes,
the church takes over,
and the church wants people to
concentrate on their souls not
on their bodies,
and washing was considered too
much of a sign of preoccupation
with the body,
and especially for women.
It's not good for women to pay
too much attention to their
bodies.
Europeans at that time,
boasted and you've probably
heard this that they only wash
three times in their lives.
How many of you have ever heard
that?
Once when they're born,
once when they get married,
and once when they die they get
washed,
and the rest of that--not only
didn't they wash they thought
that water that you washed with
carried disease,
contagion, various theories and
that if you washed you would
probably get sick from the
washing.
The solution was not
cleanliness--the solution to the
bad conditions--
but perfume,
and perfume comes up in this
era because people stank so much
that,
if they had the money,
they would buy perfume.
Anybody know why--yes?
Student:  Was the water
likely to make you sick because
it was so dirty?
Prof: Good question,
was the water likely to make
them sick?
If they drank the water, yes.
If they washed in the water, no.
There's very little in
temperate zone water that's
going to get through your skin.
In tropical zones there can be
parasites in there and they can
be dangerous,
but in Europe I'm not sort of
aware of anything that washing
in the water will get you sick.
Student:  On the hand if
you wash yourself and it stays
on your skin and then you eat or
something could you then get
sick?
Prof: Yes,
if you wash yourself,
it stays on your skin and then
you eat with your unwashed
hands--
well probably what was on there
before you washed is going to be
worse.
In general, I think nobody
washed unless something comes
off--the burden of whatever's on
the skin gets less.
All of these things are what we
modern people think about,
but obviously,
back then, just these kind of
very simple straightforward
questions were not really
considered.
People back then,
George Washington,
King George wore wigs--anybody
know why?
Some of you probably know why
they wear wigs--underneath the
wig was--
Student:  Head lice.
Prof: Lots of lice,
shaved heads,
they had lice.
Lice was endemic,
they couldn't get rid of it,
so they shaved their heads.
I think we just saw that on
television with the John Adams
story.
Every so often--did any of you
see that TV show?
HBO--anyway he takes off his
wig and there he is bald,
that was to prevent lice.
One of the reasons--one of the
major reasons for this lack of
population growth for hundreds
of years in Europe,
just no idea about sanitation,
hygiene,
any of this kind of stuff.
Another aspect which you'll be
reading about is infanticide.
Infanticide was a very large
factor in European demography
and the rest of the world,
as you will read about,
but in Europe it was very
important.
There was always a level of
infanticide and--
of various sorts but in the
eighteenth and nineteenth
centuries it apparently
exploded--
the number of kids that were
done away with.
In Milan, from 1840s to 1860s,
one third of all children born
to married parents--
we're not talking about
unmarried situations--
were left at foundling homes
and in foundling homes the death
rate was near 100%.
More than half of all the
children born to working class
parents were left in foundling
homes,
and almost all the illegitimate
children were abandoned and the
death rates--
it was a form of infanticide,
you just gave them to a
foundling home,
they were taken,
basically, no care of,
they died.
It was out of sight.
Again, not just the ordinary
ignorant person but you all know
Jean-Jacques Rousseau?
The famous French
philosophe who wrote a
lot that encouraged the American
Revolution.
This is a quote from him,
"My third child was thus
deposited in a foundling home
just like the first two,
and I did the same with the two
following.
I had five in all.
The arrangement seemed to me so
good,
so sensible,
so appropriate that,
if I did not boast of it
publicly,
it was solely out of regard for
their mother."
There was no--here they're
abandoning these children to
almost certain death and
it--there was just no moral
compunction about it whatsoever.
Aside from absolute abandonment
to foundling homes or …
just leaving them in the
streets--
you'll read about American and
England where the kids were just
often left in the streets.
Another mechanism was sending
out children to nurse with wet
nurses and the death rate of wet
nurse children was enormously
high.
So, if parents tried to rear
their children,
the death rate was about one in
six at this time.
In eighteenth century France
between a half and two-thirds of
infants that were sent out to
nurse died.
Even at a higher death rate
were the so called baby farms,
in the nineteenth century
Europe there were--
it's like we call them puppy
mills now,
they were baby farms,
and they took in vast numbers
of children presumably to wet
nurse,
but almost none of them
survived.
As I showed you from these and
all kinds of reasons,
about a third of children died
in infancy.
The idea of being a parent and
the family idea of childrearing
was completely different then we
now understand.
The standard thing was a child
was born, it was almost
immediately sent out to wet
nurse, someone that doesn't care
about them.
A lot was written about wet
nurses getting drunk,
having the baby in bed,
getting drunk,
rolling over on the baby and
squashing the baby.
Whether that was an excuse or
the real reason for the child's
death is unknown.
They would wet nurse for a
couple of years and then those
that were still alive would come
back home,
maybe age two or three or
something,
and then by age seven they
would be sent back out to work
again as an apprentice
somewhere.
How many have read Charles
Dickens: David
Copperfield,
and Oliver Twist?
What age were they sent out to
work?
Seven.
Seven is the standard age,
there are scenes of one of the
Dicken's characters going to
work in a dye factory dying
cloth,
and he comes out black every
day, covered with the dye.
That was quite a standard thing.
In 1646, the rich and very
progressive town of Leyden in
the Netherlands,
Lehyden was one of the most
advanced places in Europe,
limited the working day for
children to 14 hours,
whether the law was obeyed or
not we don't know,
but children could not do that.
Of course Charles Dickens is a
couple of hundred years later in
the nineteenth century.
Apparently, in every one of his
novels, there's some scene of
child labor going on.
Now I'm talking about up to the
1800s but this does not
disappear.
Now you look what Europe--the
situation Europe was in,
in 1800--some of the developing
countries are currently in.
So official figures from India,
the government figures,
say there are 12 million child
workers in India.
Opponents, activists on the
labor issue, estimate that it's
closer to 60 million children in
India are working.
They do have child labor laws
now in India and they prohibit
children under age 14 from
working in hazardous jobs.
When the scandal about Gap,
our clothing manufacture Gap
came out,
the factories that were
investigated had children as
young as ten years old working
up to 16 hours a day making the
dungarees …
that we wear.
All of this sort of misery
leads not only to physical
misery but change in attitude
toward life,
and death came very easily,
it was very common and so life
was cheaper.
There's no question about it
from the literature that life
was cheaper then we consider
now.
Because children especially
were so likely to die,
as well as anyone else,
it was considered imprudent,
not wise, to be particularly
affectionate with or emotionally
entwined with any other human
being.
Your husband might die
immediately, your kids might
die, your wife might die.
And so as far as we can tell
from the writings of the period,
what we call affective
relationships,
emotional relationships were
rather cool in this period,
except of course violent anger
which always pops out.
Going back to this,
here's all these problems,
and what did people do about
some of these things?
An idea of disease comes from
the Greeks and probably farther
back then the Greeks,
that the body is controlled by
four humors,
fluids that run around the
body, something like the Chi of
Oriental thought.
And these four humorous must be
in balance.
When you got sick the problem
was that the humors got out of
balance.
One of the things you did was
get bled.
That was a standard procedure;
let the blood flow because that
gets rid of the evil humors.
George Washington was
apparently killed by an excess
of bloodletting,
so when he was older he got
quite sick and the doctors--
while he was sick,
bled five pints of blood out of
him and then he died.
We take--when we go to take
blood they take one pint and
they consider that sort of the
maximum safe amount for young
healthy people.
Here he was old and sick,
five pints, he dies.
His nemesis--George Washington
in America and King George III
in England--you know the saying,
mad King George?
He was mad and he was mad with
a genetic disease called
porphyria which affects the
hemoglobin in the blood.
It caused episodic madness,
so he would be sane,
then he would be would mad,
then he would be sane,
then he would be mad,
and when he was mad what did
they do?
They bled him;
they bled him enormously.
They tied him to a chair,
they did all kinds of things to
him.
They had no clue either how to
handle any of these diseases nor
of a humane way,
no idea of a humane way to
treat someone who has something
wrong with them that you have no
clue what it is or what to do
about this.
If you ever want to see that,
there's a great movie,
The Madness of King
George, about 1995 if you
ever want to--
it describes this aspect of his
life.
Leeches, another form of this
bloodletting was,
instead of taking a razor blade
or a blade and cutting a vein,
which is hard to sew up,
leeches are wonderful.
You stick leeches on you and
the blood--
leeches suck out the blood and
we know this goes back at least
to the ancient Romans and it was
practiced for 2000 years,
this bloodletting,
on this ancient theory of the
humors.
1860, we have data,
in the hospitals just in
London, so in 1860 that was Rule
Britannia.
England was the richest,
most educated ruler of the
whole world in 1860.
In the hospitals in one city,
London--7 million leeches were
used.
The idea again being that until
you know what you're doing,
you don't know what you're
doing and just use anything and
it's all--
no evidence whatsoever that any
of this ever helped anybody,
and of course we now know it
was in fact--
not only didn't it help them,
it made them sicker.
We now have sort of a rage in
America and Europe for natural
medicine, and its various
versions.
Well this has a very old
history and so how many know the
author Wilkie Collins,
Moonstone,
Woman in White,
it's one of the--they're on PBS
Television all the time,
you've seen them.
He had gout which was--what
happens is back then they ate a
lot of meat, had a lot of
protein in the blood,
the breakdown part,
protein is urea.
If you don't excrete it fast
enough it's not very soluble.
It crystallizes in your joints
and then every time you move a
joint these little sharp
crystals grind in there and it
makes it very hard to move and
your joints get swollen;
a very, very unpleasant disease.
What did they do for gout?
Late in the 1880s they treated
gout with a poultice of cabbage
leaves covered with silk,
with oiled silk,
and this particular author,
Wilkie Collins wrote about it,
that's how we know some of the
details and it didn't give him
any relief whatsoever.
Surprise, surprise.
What he did,
he turned to opium to dull the
pain because opium really does
work,
it's the basis of morphine and
he probably died partly of opium
poisoning because it does other
bad things to your system.
Now continuing this story of
what happened,
this all relates to death rates
in pre-scientific times.
You American history buffs,
what happened to President
James Garfield?
He was assassinated,
he was shot,
but he wasn't really--
he was shot but he wasn't
really assassinated because he
lived like for a year after he
was shot.
So whether you call that
assassination or not,
I don't know.
The bullet went in--apparently
into his back and lodged in some
fat.
Now fat is not very permeable
to anything,
the bullet lodged in a lump of
fat,
the lead doesn't--the lead
poisoning from the bullet
doesn't get out,
nothing much gets out so it's
not a really dangerous thing to
have a bullet in a lump of fat.
His doctors,
and some of them were
homeopaths,
which was the big thing back
then, and some were allopaths--
what those words mean you can
ask me after class,
and they had opposing theories.
Homeopaths thought that
whatever is wrong with you--
so I am telling you the
theories--whatever was wrong
with you,
you should give a little bit of
the same thing and that would
cure you,
and little bit meant you could
dilute it infinitely so that
there's actually nothing in what
they were giving you,
maybe pure water but that was
supposed to cure you.
Allopath was supposed to give
them something of the opposite,
and there's been--you can see
it in every drugstore nowadays,
homeopathic remedy and what
that legally means is,
there's nothing in it but
that's okay.
They had these opposite
theories and they kept fighting
about what to do with this
President who was sick,
so what they did is,
they stuck metal rods into his
wound to try to pull the bullet
out even though the bullet was
doing no danger,
although sterilization--Lister
had done his work--
was known already,
these doctors didn't believe in
that,
so they stuck in these metal
rods with no sterilization.
He of course got infected,
apparently not from the bullet
because he lived a year,
but from the metal rods that
they kept poking into him.
Their understanding of,
or their interest in,
physiology was so nil that they
insisted, for reasons that I
have not found,
that he be fed rectally.
They fed him beef bouillon,
egg yolks, milk,
whiskey, and drops of opium
rectally.
The problem is the rectum does
not absorb food;
the purpose of the rectum is to
take water out and conserve
water.
They're feeding him this way,
this was the only way he was
allowed to be fed.
It's not healthy to put food in
this way and so what happens,
what do you think happens?
He loses weight;
how much does he lose?
A 100 pounds from July to
September.
In three months this guy loses
100 pounds.
Does anybody notice this?
Does anybody pay attention to
this?
Does anybody have the
scientific cast of mind that,
'well I have a theory and I'm
applying that theory,
and, oh my, it's not working,
so maybe my theory is wrong.'
No, that's just not the
critical scientific mindset.
They knew that that was the
right thing to do and so they
would not give up their theories
and basically it seems he
starved to death.
They infected him and starved
him to death.
What happens when new ideas do
come out in a pre-scientific
era?
One of the current public
health measures is you don't eat
food with your hands.
Your mother tells you that all
the time,
because you wash your hands
first which they didn't do,
but even then you eat with a
knife and fork,
which your mother has--or your
dishwasher has--
cleaned very nicely.
Europeans of course,
as you've seen from any movie,
ate with their hands for many
hundreds of years,
but at that time the Arabs were
much more civilized then we
were;
we, the Europeans,
and so in the Levant,
the middle eastern coast there,
where Venice had lots of
commerce they were already
eating with knives and forks--
used a fork.
Well this was first introduced
into the Europe by the Duke of
Venice,
the Doge of Venice,
and his wife became aware that
the Arab civilization was doing
this thing of eating with forks
and she thought she would
introduce it into her dinner
parties.
She started having forks at her
dinner parties.
And the cardinal--one of the
cardinals at that time was St.
Peter Damien and he says
that--he was just totally
opposed to this.
And the idea was that the stuff
that you eat are animals and
plants,
they're God's creations,
and that by using a fork she
had set herself up above God's
creation and the quote is,
"To touch meat with a fork
was impiously to declare that
God's creatures were not worthy
of being touched by human
hands."
That kind of phrase was
repeated all the way into the
seventeenth century and forks
came very slowly into Europe.
Lightning rods.
When Benjamin Franklin invented
lightning rods what was most
likely to get struck by
lightning?
It was a church steeple,
right, because they stuck up
into the sky and had points.
As you may know,
if you take physics points
attract lightning,
pointy things,
so churches were always getting
lightning and burned out.
Benjamin Franklin invents the
lightning rod,
and oh my God,
the opprobrium that he came
under because lightning was
obviously one of God's
creations,
that he was punishing people
with it.
Now Benjamin Franklin was
interfering with God's
punishment.
Going back to the family,
which is relevant to the
population more than lightning.
So one of the--of this whole
brutal society in which life is
very insecure,
people are very violent to each
other,
they're not careful with their
persons or anything like that.
Childrearing practices don't
escape this whole context in
which people lived.
And the traditional Christian
view in the West,
and this was strongly
reinforced by Calvinist theology
after the reformation,
was that children were born
with original sin.
Original sin is the view of
human nature.
What is human nature considered
to be in these times?
Now we think of human nature as
genes versus environment,
but back then it was original
sin and children were born into
sin.
The only hope of holding the
sin in check was thought to be
the most ruthless repression of
child's will and its total
subordination to the will of the
parents.
He was subordinate to his
parents, to school masters,
and to anyone with authority
over him.
Theologians and moralists
insisted that parents ruthlessly
crush the wills of young
children by physical force if
necessary.
That has political
ramifications.
If you're taught when you're
young,
and your parents believe,
that the most moral thing is
that you must be obedient,
you must not have a will of
your own;
this leads you to believe that
authoritarian political
structures are the normal and
right way that humans should be
governed.
The American Puritans were very
much a part of this and the
primary concern with respect to
childbearing of American
Puritans was in making children
sin free enough to merit an
afterlife,
so they threatened totally
healthy children by telling them
that they would soon die.
Jonathan Edwards,
for whom one of the Yale
Colleges is named and he was
President of Princeton,
he was not President of Yale;
once I said he was I was wrong.
He lectured a group of
children: "I know you will
die in little time.
Some sooner than others.
It is not likely you will all
live to grow up."
Children's storybooks,
one of the popular children's
books was A Token for
Children:
"If other children die,
why may not you sicken and
die?"
Again, we try to protect our
children nowadays,
nurturing, loving,
try to protect our children
from these worries but back then
it (1) it was a reality,
and (2) that reality was used
to suppress their-- what was
called then their will and
subject them to enforcement by
the parents.
Of course in the literature
there's a--
this sort of reading of history
came about 50 years ago when
this was sort of noticed and
there's been a large reaction to
it that no--
some parents at least were
loving during this long stretch
of European history,
and of course,
not all parents were sort of--
so brutal to their children but
some were.
They were--one of the things
was to force a child into the
mold, the behavioral mold that
you like and also into the
physical mold.
So girls were supposed to have
narrow bodices,
narrow waists,
there's at least one case on
record where a girl was put into
an iron cage to squeeze her,
and as she grew older the cage
squeezed more and more and she
couldn't breathe and she died of
suffocation from being put in
this iron cage to mold her
physical body to the shape that
was wanted by the parents.
The conclusion is that life in
this pre-- modern,
pre-scientific times was not
only sort of miserable in the
physical sense but probably also
quite miserable in an emotional,
inward kind of sense.
That people were not warm and
loving to each other very much
but very frequently cold and
disciplining and controlling
kind of people.
We have some centuries of this
period and you can go back to
maybe the fall of the Roman
Empire when really learning
about reality in the West kind
of stopped with the fall of
Rome,
so you have more than 1,000
years where sort of no
intellectual progress with
respect to reality is made.
Then things all of a sudden
start to change and we're going
to talk about that now.
Within 200 years the death rate
falls dramatically and so has
the birth rate--falls
dramatically.
These changes are sort of the
centerpiece of what,
of course in
demography--historical
demography anybody that usually
studies--
is called the demographic
transition: the fall in the
death rate and the fall in the
birth rate.
You'll hear this many times
because it's so basic that in
these periods,
old periods the birth rate is
very high, the death rate is
very high.
They're about equal so
population basically grows not
at all or very,
very slowly.
What we're going to talk about
now in turn is first,
the fall in the death rate,
and the second,
then the fall in the birth
rate, and then theories that we
have to explain these enormous
changes in what it means to be a
human being.
What happened--we don't know
the causes or we have many,
many theories.
Maybe we many,
many times know what the causes
are.
One of the standard textbooks
of European History says--
this is going back to the wars
of religion which is just before
all these changes started
happening before Galileo,
for instance--"One thing
was clear, 130 years of
senseless bloodletting in the
name of religion inevitably
sparked off a reaction in the
minds of intelligent people.
The wars of religion offered
fertile soil for the fragile
seeds of reason and science.
People began to realize that
religiosity was hostile to
civilization."
Europeans say,
because of this period of sort
of utter irrationality,
that the bad results of it were
so immediately obvious to
everyone.
Everyone was getting scared of
getting killed by the people in
the neighboring town who were of
the other religion;
they rejected all that and were
ready for some sort of a
rational attitude toward things.
The results of that we can see
were really quite dramatic.
Here is what we can reconstruct
of life expectancy and going
back 8,000 years ago where the
records are very poor,
but it certainly wasn't much
better than this.
And there was wavering,
and probably some slow increase
in life expectancy.
This, just above 20 years of
life expectancy is what I showed
you in the graph of Cisalpine
Gaul from Roman Times and what
I've told you is true of Europe
during these hundreds of years
that I've been talking about.
That stays more or less the
same with perhaps some
improvement.
It doesn't matter whether
you're looking at France-the
dotted line, or you're looking
at China-the solid line.
As far as we can tell they're
pretty much the same until
around 1700,
all of a sudden something
majorly changes and the life
expectancy goes--
starts going sky high.
We're talking about not just
one of many,
many things that happened in
history that you can take all
kinds of history courses about,
but in terms of what it means
to be a human,
you finally can stay alive
beyond the age of 20 or 25.
That is such a tremendous
change in life that there's
nothing else as important.
Of course a large part of this,
to reinforce this,
was infant mortality.
Look what happens,
back here it's going up and
down like crazy and it's very
high.
This a quarter of children and
this is European data,
so this is about a fifth to a
quarter of children die as
children and it's out of
control.
You can see that the epidemics
come through and then times get
good, and then something else
comes through,
and so it's very variable and
very high.
Then it starts swooping
downward, and not only does it
come down but it evens out,
that we start getting control,
not only over the overall level
but all the things which cause
these wild swings in it.
Again, an amazing change in
what it means to be human.
Well what is this date where
things start happening?
1770s we're into the
Enlightenment and you all have
probably, at least in your high
school history,
have heard of the
Enlightenment.
And that is the big opening out
in Europe of rational discourse
on almost everything,
and everything from science to
politics.
Disease, for instance,
was considered divine
punishment upon mankind for
their sins, that's a quote from
somewhere.
Medical research was considered
sacrilegious.
Dissection of cadavers what
objected to because "If you
cut the bodies into pieces
what's going to happen to them
at the time of the
resurrection?"
There are all kinds of reasons
that you shouldn't do anything
to get even the most basic
knowledge of what's inside a
human body and without that you
can't make any progress.
The major, major event in the
enlightenment is Newton's
Principia.
Newton's discussion of
something that sounds rather
abstract.
What he was worried about was
how the bodies go around in
heaven.
That's what everyone was trying
to figure out.
You may remember Copernicus had
already said that things didn't
go around the earth but they
went around the sun that was
older.
Keppler had gotten the
mathematics right,
so they went around not in
circles but in ellipses,
but nobody had any explanation
for this.
It was a simple theory;
it was great regularity,
but no one had any idea why.
Newton's gravitation was what
made it rational in the sense of
understanding that it was just a
simple force of gravity and
people don't always understand
the--
you know the story of the apple
dropping on his head?
The story is that gave him the
idea of gravitation.
Apparently--(1) the story is
probably apocryphal totally but
the import is what everyone was
trying to figure out was the
heavenly motions.
The moon around the earth,
the earth around the sun,
the planets around all of these
sorts of things.
He goes to sleep under the tree
and the apple falls on his head
and he wakes up and he realizes,
'oh my God the apple fell on my
head for the same reason that
the moon is held in orbit around
the earth.'
As you know if there was no
gravity the moon would just--
here's the earth,
the moon goes around,
you shut off gravity the moon
goes off in a straight line
forever.
That was kind of understood
already by Galileo,
that things in motion will go
in a straight line unless you
pull them in somehow.
They knew that the earth--the
moon was constantly falling
toward the earth.
The earth was constantly
falling toward the sun;
all the planets were constantly
falling towards the sun.
That was understood,
and they knew that apples fell
to the earth but they didn't put
the two of them together.
The great insight of Newton
apparently was realizing that
this thing on earth that we
could observe and measure on
earth,
was the same reason that the
heavens worked,
and this was sort of a
bombshell that led to the whole
theory of celestial mechanics
and gravitation and all of
Western science really starts
from this.
Within 25 years--and people
were--Newton was lionized during
his lifetime.
It was realized what a
tremendous achievement this was,
and the relationship to this is
not only the scientific
achievement that the planets
orbited by the same force which
drops an apple,
but it was previously believed
that yes well events on earth
might work by some sort of
physical laws,
you had Galileo working on
that, but heaven was ruled by
supernatural laws,
and now Newton's great insight
was,
no they're the same laws.
That there's nothing special or
different about the heavens.
That they work by exactly the
same laws as stones and apples
falling on earth.
This was really a tremendous
impetus to realize the power of
rationality and so within 25
years the whole attitude about
everything changes tremendously.
As the bubonic plague receded,
for reasons we don't know,
that I showed you that data,
then smallpox starts becoming
the leading cause of death;
one replacing the other.
As opposed to what had gone on
before,
which was supernatural ideas
about it,
in the 1710s very shortly after
Newton,
The Royal Scientific Society
again started,
at this same time,
began a search program,
research program to gather
information from any place in
the world on how smallpox could
be controlled or cured.
Just a new kind of way of
dealing with disease that just
hadn't been seen before,
and so what did they find?
They found that,
in Turkey, that they were
inoculating people,
and what inoculation is,
the early form--they take
someone that has the disease;
they take pus from the
disease--what is pus?
It's white blood cells that
have eaten the virus or
bacteria,
depending on whether it's
plague or smallpox,
and have engulfed it and they
kill the bacteria or virus,
the pathogen.
You have a dead pathogen but
it's molecules are still there
and so you can take the pus,
inject it, just cut the skin,
put it on a person,
and hopefully they're not
exposed to anymore of the live
virus but the dead--
presumably the white blood
cells have killed the virus,
and you just get their
molecules and that induces an
immune reaction and you become
immune to this disease.
Local governments started--I'll
tell you more about smallpox in
a couple of minutes.
In 1750s, again this very early
time, local regulations for
sewage disposal are getting
started.
In the 1790s the rich start
using water closets which are
toilets of some sort.
Not only do they introduce
vaccination, but 1796 they try
to make it better.
They don't just say,
oh this works by some magic,
they try to figure out what it
makes it better,
and Jenner discovers
vaccination, which is instead of
using pus from a person who had
smallpox--
there's a very closely related
disease called cowpox which the
cow maids--
the milk maids get very
frequently,
and it was noticed,
because they're now observing
all these things,
that these women would get sick
but most of them would recover.
This was a not a lethal
disease, so instead of taking
the actual smallpox virus,
which vaccination--the early
inoculation--
did not always work and you
sometimes did catch the disease
and died.
Taking it from cowpox rather
than smallpox was less
dangerous,
but since the viruses are
closely related to each other a
lot of the molecules are the
same and you get--
from cowpox you get immunity to
smallpox and so these diseases
start going down.
Not only in health but it
starts the industrial
revolution, in 1711 James
Newcomen invents the steam
engine.
It's a very,
very inefficient steam engine,
and it's used only where you
had--can have a very big
placement and it's used to pump
water out of mines.
Coal is becoming important for
England to fuel the industrial
revolution, and you have mines
that are underground,
and water seeps into them.
You've got to suck out the
water, so how do you pump it
out, well he invents the steam
engine.
Then James Watt figures
out--looks at it more
scientifically,
more rationally,
and again just like inoculation
being supplanted with
vaccination they start
improving.
It's not just that something
works and our ancestors did it
this way and we don't know why
it works,
we don't why care it works,
we do it the same way our
ancestors did.
No they keep thinking about
what they're looking at,
what they're working on,
and he improves it and in this
case what James Watt did is,
after the steam comes out,
he had a condenser to condense
the steam so drop the pressure
on one side of the piston going
out.
Just by taking the condenser
instead of--
letting--having a way of
cooling the steam really
improves the efficiency of a
steam engine and now with a
greater efficiency you can make
a smaller steam engine that
works just as well,
and you can put it on wheels
and you start getting the
railroad and all kinds of
smaller factories can start
using steam engines.
In politics,
this idea is also terribly
important.
The previous idea was that of a
hierarchical system with God
appointing kings being--
ruling over nobility and then
everyone else must obey up this
chain.
Well what is Newton's idea?
That everything obeys the same
law: gravity.
That the sun attracts the earth;
the earth attracts the sun,
equally and opposite.
There's no difference.
The sun does not rule the
universe, it's not better then
the earth, it works by exactly
the same rules.
The sun and the earth,
the earth and the moon,
everything acts by the same
rules, there is no need for some
sort of central sentient
coordinator of all this,
but each individual planet,
each individual body,
all bodies, apples,
working by their own laws,
by the same laws as everyone
else the universe works
beautifully.
In fact it works as it does it
work.
This idea is very consciously
taken over into politics and the
idea of democracy,
again changes that each person
acting under his own desires,
his own self interest,
his own morality can,
by interacting in the same way
the planets do,
can come out with a system that
works.
The original theorists of
democracy were very conscious of
this shift in the way they
looked at the way the universe
worked and very conscious of
its--
their debt to Newton on that.
In economics,
how many of you are economics
majors?
The bust has really taken
effect;
we used to have lots of
economic majors.
What is Adam Smith's idea?
The basis of modern economics
is Adam Smith's--
that no you don't need a
Mercantilist government to
control everything,
that if each person acts in
their own self interest by their
own internal rules,
then the economy will work just
wonderfully and be more
productive.
Freedom of religion is again
the same thing,
freedom of conscience,
it's a similar kind of idea
that each person has its own--
has his own way of working
things out and that does not
destroy the harmony of the
universe.
We see that this rationality
changes everything about the way
humans live.
One of its most important
effects is demography.
That the population stops dying
and can start increasing,
and this is exactly what
happens.
As all this rational attitude
toward death and toward disease
starts taking hold,
the death rate falls
tremendously as I've shown you,
the life expectancy goes up,
infant mortality goes down,
and population starts
increasing tremendously.
Most people,
at that time,
believed that a big population
was a wonderful thing and
they're very optimistic about
it,
and one of the standard ways of
judging a government,
when you saw a country that had
a lot of people in it,
well obviously the government
was doing something right.
The king at that time was doing
something right because people
were able to stay alive.
If you saw a country with a low
population, well something was
wrong, and that was not
necessarily an improper
attitude.
Up until Malthus,
with some exceptions,
it was generally the idea that
there was no limit to
population, that the more the
population the merrier.
Malthus came along and said,
'hmm there is a problem with
population,' and he had been
watching--he collected very good
data.
You read his stuff,
it's really wonderful to read
because it's extremely modern in
that he tells you the data he is
collecting;
he analyzes it;
he tells you what he--what's
wrong with the data,
why he believes it to a certain
extent but not beyond that and
all things about the data.
Very--he's writing is like 1798
but it reads like a modern PhD
thesis, just about.
His knowledge was the
following, and it's very simple
what he said.
He did not say--many people
thought that--
as previous people had often
said like Edmond Burke,
who was the father of
conservatism,
that the economic pie is
constant, there's just so much
stuff out there,
and the more people you just
have to divide the pie smaller
and smaller.
That's one way of looking at it.
Then it's perfectly obvious
that population is a bad thing
because there's fixed production
and you have more people to eat
up that production.
Malthus was much smarter,
by the time he wrote in 1798
the Enlightenment had started to
produce results.
He could see that agricultural
production was improving year by
year;
modern methods were--modern at
that time--were beginning to
take over and he knew that
production rose.
What he assumed,
and what he saw from the data
was that production rose
linearly,
that every year there was sort
of--you could produce a little
bit more out of the land.
Now he said,
but what about population?
In population if you have 100
people and they increase by
let's say 50% that's 150 people,
you've gained 50 people.
But now from the next
generation you again grow by
50%, you're starting with 150
people you have--now you're
adding 75 people.
The graph--this is time,
this is agricultural product,
and Malthus said this is
growing like this,
which was quite reasonable for
his time.
Population, no matter where it
starts grows--
he called it geometrically,
we call it exponentially,
so if it starts that there's
just enough food for people to
eat,
then it almost immediately goes
above food production.
If it starts even below,
it doesn't matter;
it eventually rises--catches up
with food production and goes
beyond it.
He believed that there was no
doubt that population increases
geometrically,
or exponentially as we say,
that means a certain percent a
year.
It may increase one percent a
year or two percent a year,
or three percent a year,
but remember that's one percent
of an increasing number so it's
more and more.
Whereas, agriculture he thought
increased linearly by the same
fixed amount each year,
and if that's the case you're
going to run into starvation.
He said, since population can
always outrun productivity,
eventually you get into
trouble, that whenever you
increase the number of people--
if you ever--you're at some
sort of stasis level,
where resources fit the
population.
But then as you get some
increase in productivity it
allows a rise in population only
to match that,
but then the greater number of
people eat up that increase in
productivity so you're right
back down to where he--
you started with.
His idea was that increasing
population was not a good thing.
It could not lead to any
improvement if it outran your
productivity gains,
and this led to all kinds of
what we now consider very
conservative and even
retrogressive political ideas.
So poor laws--he was initially
against poor laws.
There's no sense to keep the
poor alive because if you keep
them alive they're going to
reproduce and make even more
children and you're right back
to where you started from.
He was a strong conservative in
that sense.
He later changed his mind as he
got smarter about things.
He was also aware of,
even though population could
increase like this,
maybe and he was aware,
that people were smart enough
to stop this in some way.
He knew about various methods
of contraception,
withdrawal and so forth,
and various perverse sexual
practices.
But he was so opposed to them
morally,
as was everyone else in his
time, that you should not
control reproduction,
that that was immoral,
but he said 'people are never
going to do that.'
That what happens to balance it
is not people themselves
controlling this in a very
rational way,
which he thought was not
possible at that time,
but famine would come in,
disease would come in,
and whenever your population
got too big people would get
very poor.
They were open to some disease,
the disease would wipe you out.
You either starved directly
immediately from too much--
the population getting ahead of
agriculture productivity,
you either starved or you got
to so weak that diseases come
through and wipe you out.
Okay we will--time is up we
will continue onward next time.